I'm worried about stopping the anti-cancer supplements that are bothering my gut.
So this person did a Syrex 10 recently.
Syrex array 10 is a test for food antibodies.
So if you have antibodies to different foods and you eat those foods, it's going to cause
inflammation in your gut and in your body and in your brain and in everywhere.
So remember inflammation in the gut equals inflammation in the brain.
And so you don't want to be eating foods that are causing inflammation.
This is why I stress to you guys over and over again that running some antibody tests
to test for other cold morbidities can be extremely beneficial in your desire to get better
from cancer.
So we can't forget that just because we have cancer doesn't mean we don't have other
things that are continuing to participate in the continued growth of my cancer.
So what would be one of the things that would continue to aid the growth of my cancer?
Well it is chronic inflammation or what could cause chronic inflammation antibodies to things
that we're exposed to antibodies to foods that were eating foods that were eating are the
most common things because you're eating every day.
So if you're eating something that you are that is causing inflammation it's causing systemic
inflammation not just in your gut and when you're causing systemic inflammation how are
you going to get better from anything?
Not just cancer.
So if some of the supplements that are deemed anti-cancer supplements have things in it that
you have antibodies against like tumeric so you can't take curcum in then you can't take
it.
So you know you go okay well I need this because this is what's going to knock my cancer
down.
Well taking that particular thing that's causing inflammation the gut is going to make your
cancer worse if you don't deal with that.
So you have to that's why running that test is so important.
So stop being worried about it.
So do I send a cheek swabs you can find different supplements?
No just stop those things.
Sometimes you just need to cut things out to decrease the inflammation you needed.
This is where fasting is beneficial this is why people I know a person that did a fast
and they really helped their autoimmune disease well it's because they changed their diet that's
where you hear about people that go on a carnivore diet and they cure their autoimmune
disease.
Well they're good as they didn't have antibodies to different meat proteins but if they don't
have antibodies to meat proteins and they all they do is eat meat proteins and they do everything
they can to heal their gut they're going to heal their gut then if they're not caused they're
not eating foods that are causing inflammation elsewhere.
Oh okay do I send a cheek swab in no maybe it is time to rotate them.
Anyways or with my gut with my gut so bad maybe I am not absorbing anything so it's
time to prioritize even further maybe I wasted money.
It's not really a question in there but just you have to follow what's on the array 10 and
stay off those things and I know it's difficult.